as if this one sucks can this just be
the end of it can this be the end of the
attempts to show us Dark Phoenix I mean
does it look better than last and
probably will be I'm getting ahead of
myself first we had a trailer for the
Dark Phoenix or x-men Dark Phoenix
whatever they're calling it and we see
gene like grieving she's like oh what if
it happens she was my friend and you see
her talking to Jennifer Lawrence and
maybe mystique dives maybe they just
showed us that in the trailer maybe
they're trying to give the fans what
they want what if fans been screaming
about for a couple movies now likewise
Jennifer Lawrence here it looks like
she's phoning it in she wants out of the
contract what this movie should be calls
like x-men the ending of Jennifer
Lawrence's contract is so powerful she
can destroy anything
let her rip up the contract but the
facts just something like that in this
trailer either means they're giving us a
rope-a-dope like it doesn't happen or
they're just being like hey look guys
look you've been screaming about it
forever for years he gotta get those
asses in the seats somehow the thing
about this trailers what is there to say
about this trailers trailers actually
pretty simple
other than mystique probably most
definitely but probably dying jeans
snaps becomes the Dark Phoenix she's bad
they got a stopper at least she's not
Magneto's Lackey in this movie at least
they're illustrating she's powerful
enough to be her own person
and because Charles Xavier apparently
it's his fault in the last trailer they
show that Xavier thought he repressed
something in her mind which is exactly
the plot of x-men The Last Stand so I
have that kind of acting as goggles over
this trailer it's like no but there's
still that that x-men molest and [ __ ]
that's the residual [ __ ] here and of
course we have stories from people who
have apparently screened the movie that
I don't know though have they screened
the movie the chatter is this movie's
probably gonna be asked I don't
subscribe to that I don't know those
[ __ ] people so I'm giving this movie
to benefit of the doubt I will judge
this movie by what I see here and what I
see here is it's bad person to super
powerful and they've got a stopper super
powerful being the x-men have to stop
that super powerful being otherwise
super powerful beings gonna wipe out a
lot of life on Earth but enough about
x-men apocalypse hello because that is
the plot of the last movie we've seen it
we've seen a lot of it in terms of x-men
movies it's not new anymore
the saga as a whole is nearly twenty
years old we've seen a lot of stuff
we've seen the great stuff we've seen
the trips as slip-ups the absolute [ __ ]
we've seen that which inspired us we've
seen that which made us want to vomit
movie doesn't look like it's gonna give
us anything new I think it's gonna be
cool to see gene tear people apart is
she actually gonna tear people apart
will they do that too
her is she actually gonna kill people is
that how they're gonna do it I mean
magneto looks like he's in bad shape in
that saying maybe everyone's getting out
of their contracts in this one maybe
this is how they're gonna end it now
that x-men could go over to Marvel I
feel like that moments like straight-up
gonna be pulled from Justice League
flash running around Superman but
Superman is fast enough to see him and
stop some it's not that the trailer
doesn't do anything for me it just
doesn't give me any sensation other than
hey that could be entertaining big fire
lady could kill people or at least put
people in danger of being killed
possibly definitely kills one of her
friends do in the end new Dark Phoenix
trailer a lot of things lining up to
make me go alright hope it's good what
I'm hoping for for this movie I'm not
expecting greatness
I'm not even hoping for greatness I'm
hoping that this movie is at least
entertaining to me that's all I want at
this point I just want Dark Phoenix to
be entertaining it's not like Phoenix is
in a movie that keeps Phoenix bogged
down with other plot lines about mutants
being cured or whatever the movie seems
to be committing to Dark Phoenix that
frees up a lot of screen time to flesh
out the plot it incorporates space there
is that so it's at least that much more
accurate than x-men The Last Stand it'll
probably be better than x-men the last
time you guys remember that ingress
cross will say the point is the new Dark
Phoenix trailer have you seen it what
did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you liked what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more sorry I wasn't
more helpful in this video I just I
don't know what else to say except hope
it's good
[Music]